a week since the election was called
enough people call it rigged
enough for confrontation like this
[Music]
outside the grounds of the white house
this was the friday scene
inside was a president seldom scene
of the united states we hadn't seen
donald trump do a public engagement in
over a week
in the rose garden there wasn't the
campaign trail energy
this seemed a president grayed out thank
you very much
right down to his hair color as soon as
april the vaccine will be available to
the entire general population
he talked covert vaccine but not career
prospects
though there was this this
administration will not be going to a
lockdown hopefully the
the whatever happens in the future who
knows which administration will be i
guess time will tell but
uh i can tell you this administration
will not go to a lockdown
he hesitated on talk of a next
administration
maybe just maybe an acknowledgment that
he knows this white house appearance
might be one of his last
a sparse engagement calendar had
otherwise taken donald trump outside
only for veterans day at arlington
cemetery this week
a long walk into a graveyard under storm
clouds
the metaphors write themselves for an
ailing president
but he's not reading them the united
states
is still steeped in the politics of its
presidency about who belongs in the
white house
we've had a glimpse here of the
political fallout it's not just about
him in there
it's about them out here but he lost the
election
the media does not decide india does not
decide who they are
the media are propagandists the voters
decided by numbers
you only count legal votes in this
country you shouldn't have
anxiety like this around elections and
around you know standard processes like
this
it's it's disheartening for sure yeah
worrying
very yeah
there'll surely come a time when the
politics around pennsylvania avenue
regain their rhythm harmony might take
a little longer james matthews sky news
washington